deep in the heart of Wayzata Minnesota
lies one of the biggest family dynasties
in America except you've never heard of
their name this family Dynasty made more
money last year than Coca-Cola Nestle
and Chevron combined in fact they're the
largest private company in the US and
this single company controls a massive
share of your food supply they're
responsible for supplying food for some
of the biggest brands out there like
McDonald's Burger King Kellogg's Mars
Dunkin Donuts Unilever Safeway Kroger
Albertsons Audi Tesco and many many more
look in your kitchen right now and
you're gonna find a ton of food made by
this secret Mecca Corporation from cocoa
powder to cooking oil salt sugar eggs
meat but you won't find their name on
any of these labels most of you have
never even heard of this name before
that's because this American Dynasty has
worked very hard to keep it that way
they don't want you to know what they're
doing behind their Factory doors because
if you ever found out you would never
buy their food products again it's that
bad what is the name of this family you
ask carbo
[Music]
eating processed food from companies
like cargo is a Surefire way to shorten
your life but fortunately longevity
researchers like David Sinclair have
recently made some promising discoveries
on how to mitigate or even slow down
aging altogether and that is why I use
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these scientific breakthroughs into
products that hold the potential to
increase your longevity and one of their
products I take every day is cell being
cell being helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repairs
damage DNA and increases energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
even take NAD as a supplement because
it's too big for your cells to absorb
that's why Verso cell being contains
something called nmn Resveratrol and TMG
these three molecules work together to
increase NAD plus levels in your body
more than just taking one of them on
their own and that is why I take the
stuff every day plus Verso publishes
third-party testing on every batch of
his products to guarantee that you're
getting what you're paying for so if you
want to join me you can get 15 off by
going to ver.so Jake train with code
Jake Tran with the link below that's
ver.so Jake Tran with code Jake Tran
with the link below thanks to Verso for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
foreign
cargo may have started out as a single
Shack on the side of the road but today
they're a whole lot bigger cargo is the
largest private company in the US and if
they were public they would be ranked
number 15 on the Fortune 500 list just
in front of a t and cargo has his
fingers in almost every pie imaginable
from grains to livestock to palm oil and
Coca to Meadows animal feed energy and
even hedge funds the total revenue in
2021 was 135 billion dollars which is
almost double the amount of what other
big agricultural companies like ADM
Bungie and Dreyfus made that year in
fact this makes cargo bigger than the
entire GDP of Morocco but if you want to
buy some cargo shares you would be fresh
out of luck because cargo doesn't want
your peasant money it is not worth it to
them cargo has purposely remained a
private company for a lot of companies
going public on the stock market is the
dream but cargo knows that if they went
public they would have to report
everything to the shareholders which
would expose them to a lot of public
scrutiny but for what it's not like they
need the money they already secretly
control the food industry there's a
reason why their name doesn't ring a
bell why well you can't boycott
something you don't know about right and
there's a lot to boycott about
foreign
[Music]
agriculture business you're at the
constant whims of nature droughts floods
Global shortages of seeds all of that
can be a very serious threat to your
main money makers what if your primary
food exports suddenly dried up one day
and that was the exact position cargo
found themselves in in 1997 during the
Asian financial crisis see at the time
cargo was sourcing a lot of his cross
from the Philippines Taiwan Indonesia
and Korea but one Asia fell into a
financial crisis it caused a lot of the
agriculture producers cargo was buying
from to close down suddenly cargo
couldn't get soy wheat and corn from
these countries at the same price as
they were before so cargo ended up
losing 4 billion dollars which at the
time was the equivalent of eight years
of profit for them it was one of cargo's
biggest losses to date and it plunged
them into debts understandably the cargo
family panics so they shook up
management and put a new guy in charge
to hopefully lead them back to the
promised land and the man they chose to
do that was Warren stully one of cargo's
most loyal employees that had been
working there since 1969 and when War
installed stepped up as the head of
cargo he did in fact lead them back to
the promised land but at a huge cost
[Music]
cargo needed to dig themselves out of
that 4 billion dollar pits and since one
of their most lucrative cross was Coca
they went on the hut for an ultra cheap
source and they eventually found it on
the Ivory Coast during the 90s children
were being trafficked from Mali into the
Ivory Coast for slave labor these kids
weren't being paid they were barely fed
they were physically abused and were
basically held hostage on these Farms
lunch house life came forward saying
that they were forced to spray
pesticides on Coca crops without any
protective clothing others say that they
were whipped with branches and left in
solitary confinements according to other
reports children who tried to escape
were forced to drink urine as
punishments others say that their feet
were cut open and Pepper would be rubbed
into their rooms but the benefit of all
this child labor is that these first
were able to produce extremely cheap
coca so companies like Nestle Hershey
Mars and cargo put their orders in as
fast as possible in 2005 the
international labor rights fund found
out about cargo's connection to these
slave camps and filed a lawsuit against
them as of today the case though hasn't
been resolved and since then cargo has
just continued growing their coca
business in 2018 cargo put together
plans to expand their coca store houses
in abajan a city in the Ivory Coast in
2019 they invested 113 million dollars
into coca processing plants in both the
Ivory Coast and Ghana while at the same
time they keep staying there against
child labor in the Press what coca on
lockdown now cargo just needed some
cheap land
[Music]
cargo's main business is storing and
processing crops so obviously they need
cheap land to grow cheap crops on
ideally the land should be free so to
get their hands on some free land Carl
got involved with land grabbing in the
late 2000s and yes land grabbing sounds
exactly like what you think it is in
2011 one of cargo's palm oil suppliers
sent a fleet of security guards to open
fire on a nearby Indonesian Village the
reason a villager apparently stole a
piece of palm fruits which may or may
not have been true so in response the
guards evicted 100 people from their
homes and bulldozed the entire Village
to the ground coincidentally that land
provided the perfect canvas for a new
field of palm fruits a few years later
cargo soy producers in Brazil were
accused of sending a private security
Force into a nearby indigenous Village
they smashed down doors assaulted
children kicked pregnant women in the
stomach seven indigenous people were
shots several women lost their babies
and what was all this violence for
because one person from the tribe
trespassed on company Farmland but if
those indigenous people end up
abandoning their homes because of this
conveniently these indigenous people
never ended up coming back so their land
was up for grabs it was turned into more
Farmland to produce even cheaper across
for cargo to buy up
[Music]
sure a land grab here and there is nice
but in the grand scheme of things it
just wasn't enough cargo needed way more
land and conveniently in 2004 a giant
patch of natural rainforest the size of
Hawaii was being cleared out of the
Amazon rainforest
and what did they use as land for why
the most nutritious crop out there soy
soy was planted on these lands and it
was offered to foreign countries at dirt
cheap prices and cargo made sure that
they were first in line to buy but you
might remember that there was a whole
eco-friendly movement that was starting
to pick up during this time reusable
water bottles Fair Trade coffee save the
rainforest t-shirts and they did not
like what cargo was up to so Greenpeace
launched or save the Amazon campaign in
2006 and in response cargo publicly
agreed to no longer purchase soy from
the DeForest lands in the Amazon cargo
even received a special award in
environmental leadership for this new
agreement but there was a loophole
Greenpeace didn't say anything about
Serato another lesser-known rainforest
in Brazil that is still equally
important Serato contains five percent
of the war's plant in animal species and
eight of Brazil's Rivers so instead of
getting soy from the Amazon rainforest
cargo just switched to getting soy from
Serato and no one was the wiser while
deforestation of the Amazon rainforest
slowed down exponentially between 2008
and 2012 deforestation in Serato set up
fast forward to 2018 and Serato had lost
95 000 square kilometers of rainforest
that is two-thirds more than what was
ever cleared in the Amazon and the
Amazon is three times the size so a
giant chunk of the Serato rainforest is
now gone
foreign
approached cargo again and demanded that
they stopped exploiting Serato in
response cargo put on their best PR face
they didn't overtly agree to
greenpeace's demands and instead created
a cargo branded soy action plan this
plan promised that 30 million dollars
would be put towards research for
alternatives to growing crops on Native
lands it sounded very Noble very
ambitious like progress was actually
being made when in reality this plan was
as vague as can be but it worked after
they presented this plan to the world
they just turned around and went
straight back to buy soy from Serato
cargo's argument against not buying soy
from Serato is that if they moved out
someone else was just gonna move in like
China for example who buys most of
Brazil soy you wouldn't want to support
China now would you we gotta keep
supporting American jobs in the American
economy
foreign
[Music]
today cargo is a huge company they
employ over 155 000 people worldwide
they handle a quarter of the country's
total grain exports 20 of our beef and
pork comes from their factories six
million tons of sugar is shipped by
cargo each year and when you're this big
making this much money it can be easy to
let things slip through the cracks in
the year 2000 around 16 million pounds
of sliced turkey processed by cargo's
Texas plant was recalled because it was
contaminated with listeria a deadly
bacteria the meat costs seven deaths
three still bursts and 29 illnesses
across 10 American states later on that
same year a three-year-old died from E
coli poisoning after eating beef that
came from one of cargo's processing
plants in 2009 more E coli tinted
burgers were set out this time causing a
woman to become paralyzed from the waist
down why does this keep happening
because cargo had discovered an
Innovative way to save money on their
meat processing costs here's how instead
of using expensive cuts of meat to make
your Burgers you want to use all those
bits of meat and intestines that fall
onto your factory floor just scoop all
that up soak it in some ammonia to kill
the bacteria throw it into a grinder and
out comes burger patties that cost 25
less and sure fecal matter may end up in
there every now and then especially if
you're using intestines and all that
good stuff but as long as it's treated
with bleach and the animals are fed
human-grid antibiotics to reduce
infection everything should be A-Okay
just package it up and ship it out for
the masses to consume can't have a bunch
of small players delivering such an
important food source to the nation's
consumers you have to have larger
companies that can do it cheaply and can
keep costs down which brings us to today
and cargo America's tap water if you're
drinking tap water in America right now
you gotta stop because not only is it
filled with fluoride but it's also
filled with heavy metals chemicals
bacteria and guess what else you know
all those drugs that Americans take like
birth control that's filled with
hormones yeah people pee those chemicals
out it gets flushed down that Wastewater
gets sent to a water treatment plant but
most of these treatment plants in
America don't have the capability to
filter out chemicals like that so it
gets sent straight back to your tap that
means every time you're drinking from
the tap every time you're showering you
are getting an entire cocktail of these
things straight into your body and we
expose it all in our new documentary on
tap water on our other Channel evil food
supply that you can watch right now by
clicking the card on the screen click
the card on the screen to watch now
foreign